es un día que pasará a la historia para
los trabajadores de amazon tras meses de
lucha los trabajadores de un almacén de
staten island nueva york formarán el
primer sindicato del gigante tecnológico
de comercio
es un momento histórico y me siento
orgullosa de formar parte de él y lo que
significa para mí es decir estamos
cambiando la historia no sólo para los
trabajadores de amazon sino para todo el
movimiento obrero
streaming
el almacén conocido como el j efe 8
pondré en marcha un convenio colectivo
para mejorar sus condiciones laborales
tras muchas polémicas sobre las
prácticas abusivas de amazon a sus
empleados los sindicalistas atribuyen
esta victoria a christian schmutz un
trabajador que fue despedido durante la
pandemia por cuestionar los protocolos
de seguridad frente al kobe 19 y que
sentó las bases del sindicato de
trabajadores de amazon que ahora preside
queremos dar las gracias ayer beso por
el espacio porque cuando él estaba allá
arriba nosotros estamos apuntando a
gente en el sindicato una alegría que la
dirección de amazon no comparte acusada
de intentar acosar a los sindicalistas y
obstaculizar sus reuniones abiertamente
en contra de su organización
estamos decepcionados con el resultado
de las elecciones en staten island
porque creemos que tener una relación
directa con la empresa es lo mejor para
nuestros empleados
amazon es el segundo empleador de eeuu
con más de 400.000 trabajadores
destinados a la distribución de sus
productos y el debate de sindicalizarse
también ha llegado a almacenes de otros
puntos del país como el de alabama donde
recientemente ha ganado el no en medio
de acusaciones de interferencia de la
empresa